Hi! Welcome to Biology Professor.
Today we are talking about neurons structure.
Neurons are the core cell of the nervous system.
They are responsible for transmitting electrical or electrochemical signals to other cells.
The most well-known types of neurons are sensory neurons and motor neurons.
These are the cells that when you touch a hot plate,
they transmit the signal to your brain that “hey that HOT!”
These are also the neurons that allow you to move your arms around.
So let’s look at their structure.
Here is an example of a neuron.
Here we have the nucleus in black and the Soma or cell body
and you can see that branching out of one side of the Soma are multiple Dendrites.
These are like fingers. They allow the neuron to reach out into its environment
and receive signals from other cells.
These signals then propagate down what is called an Axon.
If we come over here to look at an Axon in more depth.
You will see that the Axon almost looks like beads on a string.
Here the beads are myelin sheets.
So this is when the compound myelin is wrapped around the membrane of the Axon
and it acts as an insulator.
it allows the chemical or electrical signal to propagate
down the Axon from the node to node.
So in between the myelin sheets, we see the nodes of Ranvier.
They are also called unmyelinated gaps.
and the electrical signal is able to hop, from nod to nod as it goes down the Axon.
Eventually, reaching Synaptic Knobs.
The Synaptic Knobs are able to able to reach out and connect with other Dendrites.
For example, I have drawn another neuron here.
These Synaptic Knobs can reach out to Dendrites of multiple surrounding neurons.
So that the original signal that this neuron received, gets propagated to other nearby neurons.
and that is basically how the nervous system makes things happen in your body.